キッズに出した廊下とかもため所ねまた然り
ん
厳しいなぁいやーじゃあこの部屋ととの
そこだけ気をつけております私はちょっと家のきれいなところ dqn でだ式で撮っ
てもいい
向かった是非ちゃーん座敷で動画とってもいい
ですよありがとうございますいいねいいいい感じいい感じさせてくだせ
金かかったテレビから者ぶってんじゃねーよまーっ are you
all
泉です正教会いただきました
ん
かわいいよ
2に来たようやく撮影場所を確保しました肇社長です
あのねあーくそビターっあのねぇ僕んちゃーすごい eu 中盤いいし協力的なんです
よ
が実家に帰ってきても母ちゃんからを入れて動画とるの家の外でも動画とるのペアの中
だけで動画撮れそんな状況でグレーでバードが取れないと思うんですよ俺を実家に帰っ
てきてをドントレスペ
すらないけどね今何とかちょっと話し合ってじいちゃん鶏つかん雑色
雑色で撮影していいよって言うとマミーにもなんとか説得して外でもとっていいという
許可をいただきましたら釣れたぜ肩身が狭いねユーチューバーこの僕の湯ではまあ
とりあえずこの雑誌機とお礼の部屋とことでは動画を撮って言ってはれたのでせっかく
実家に良いですね家族もみんないるんでちょっと母系はちょっと数声が入って確かめて
みたいと思う
してボクもしばらく静岡にいてねやっぱみんな僕のことをちょっともう好きじゃないか
もしれない本当の家族愛を確かめるとに僕は今から外で倒れます外で倒れてるんで
果たし誰が家族の誰が僕助けに来てくれるか心配ないとすぐ限ってきてくれると思うん
で誰か助けてく
検証してみようと思いますいい家に生まれてきたところが持ってるんで家族はでもう1
回ちょっとちゃんと確認していると思う
ます
でも行こう
家のお庭に来ましたここで今から寝っ転がるじゃあね[ __ ]ここで倒れるんで早速
誰が助けてくれるかという心配してくれる映画そこだから僕が倒れるとするわかると
思うんで果たして僕の家族の誰が僕を気遣ってくれるか
鏡が終えブーツ
ん
me
持っています
うん
ファーを
ん
バランサーん
バージョン
today ん
ありがとうございます
てい
はい
じいちゃんが家から
お土産をして小粒でるん